>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Roberto Salazar: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
This program is made
possible by the Office
of Equal Employment Opportunity
and Diversity Programs.
Our guest speaker, Sam
Martinez, served 26 years
with the Federal Bureau of
Investigation as a special agent.
Over the years the FBI assigned
him to a myriad of postings
in San Francisco, Chicago,
Denver, Mexico City, Los Angeles,
Washington, D.C. and
Montevideo, Uruguay.
He worked cases involving white
collar crime, domestic terrorism,
narcotics, foreign
counter intelligence
and undercover assignments.
He worked on the Patricia Hearst
Kidnapping, the Black Panther Party
and the FALN, a Puerto
Rican terrorist group.
In Mexico he was the FBI case agent
and supervisor to the kidnapping
and murder of DEA agent
Enrique Kiki Camarena.
His last assignment was
supervising, coordinating
and authorizing oversea
drug cases with the DEA.
He joined lead plaintiff Mat Perez
and 310 other Hispanic agents
in filing a class action lawsuit
on employee discrimination
against the FBI.
The lawsuit was not about
hatred or bigotry, but subtle
and unintentional discrimination
which became evil
when management retaliated
against those investigative agents
it relied on for its success.
The court-ordered systems
implemented
after the trial benefited the
FBI with greater opportunities
for all agents, developed
transparency and promotion policies,
and caused the FBI to promote
women at an unprecedented rate.
He is the author of Systemic Evil:
Mat Perez v. the FBI and he plans
to write books on a
less serious subjects.
The book won the Southwest
Book Award
from the Border Regional
Library Association.
Ladies and gentlemen, please join me
in welcoming our guest speaker
retired FBI special agent
Sam Martinez.
[ Applause ]
>> Samuel Martinez:
Thank you everyone.
Since it's being video, would you
please make sure you get the Library
of Congress so I can
send it to my mom.
She'll be very proud of me.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you Roberto Salazar
and the Library of Congress
for inviting this starving
artist to be here today at noon.
I appreciate you being here.
I appreciate the Library of Congress
for having me here at lunch time.
So we all have something in common;
you're a hungry audience
and I'm a hungry author.
[ Laughter ]
I am sincerely honored with the
opportunity from the Library
of Congress and for you taking the
time to listen and ask questions
at the end of my presentation.
I'm also honored that we
have retired agent Ed Mireles
in the audience.
I will read you his story and
invite him here at the end
to answer questions that
you might want it ask him.
Has anyone of you had a
chance to discriminate today?
Good I see some people.
>> I did in the cafeteria.
I got the ugly food instead
of the super ugly food.
[ Laughter ]
>> Samuel Martinez: Good.
I'm glad you raised your hand
because people are afraid
to talk about discrimination.
And discrimination- I'm going
to talk about the good side
of discrimination and the
bad side of discrimination.
Has any of you seen at least
a dozen movies of the FBI?
Seems like we all raised our hands.
Have any of you seen an agent
cry in any of those movies?
I didn't think you would.
Have any of you had your
judgement wrong about people?
I see hands going up also.
Look up the word discrimination
and you'll see
that humans discriminate every day.
Discrimination is a
decision making process.
It's a natural process within us.
Good discrimination are
choices and actions that we make
that don't affect others.
People used to say,
"He's a distinguished man
with discriminating taste."
There's nothing evil about that.
There's nothing bad about that.
We use discrimination
as a survival instinct.
Mark Cuban tried to
discuss discrimination
as a survival instinct when he
said, "I know I'm prejudiced
and I know I'm bigoted
in a lot of ways.
If I see a black kid in a hoodie
walking down the street on my side
of the street, I'll cross over
to the other side of the street.
If I see a white guy with tattoos
and a shaved head on my side
of the street, I'll walk back over
to the other side of the street.
None of us have pure thoughts."
He intended no harm to others.
He spoke his truth.
He spoke his beliefs.
He spoke his security.
And the blacks and the media and
others jumped all over his comments.
The much needed discussion ended.
A better way towards mutual
respect is to engage directly
with the moral conviction
citizens bring to life rather
than leave moral convictions aside.
We have to listen first, understand
and engage in dialogue not
when we're angry, but engage
when we want to listen.
Mild discrimination are stereotypes.
Stereotypes such as food.
Some people would say, "Do
you want chili on your tacos?"
But there's some Mexicans that
don't put chili on their tacos.
Some people don't like the taste.
We stereotype people with
noodles or fried chicken or curry.
Those are mild forms
of discrimination.
They still don't affect others,
but people are unaware how
they can effect someone
or pigeonholed someone even by
surnames, culture, language,
looks, or color of the skin.
Harmful discrimination
is protected by law.
I know Lorena Sierra is here.
She an EEO officer.
She protects the disability,
the age,
people of gender, race, ethnicity.
Those are protected by laws.
Some people use discrimination
to make themselves feel better
or making others feel less.
When used this way it's the
attackers that are making less
of themselves and less
of this country.
When you define others,
you define yourself first.
Negative discrimination
is an attempt
to steal your identity
of who you are.
No one talks about white on white
discrimination, but it happens.
Just ask William S. Sessions, former
director of the FBI, about persona
and his identity theft
by discrimination.
Our persona is more
important that our data.
Who we are is more important
than what someone else believes.
No other person is invested
in us more than we are.
Don't let anyone steal
your identity.
Oppression and injustice
are discrimination.
This book is about
work discrimination
where agents were trying to get
a fair deal, fair assignments,
fair promotions and we
were being held back.
The worst type of discriminations
come
from hate, fear and retaliation.
I was assigned to Mexico City when
the lawsuit began and I transferred
in from the Denver office.
When I transferred back
in from Denver to testify,
an agent who I had worked with,
a friend of mine, pulled me aside
and said, "Hey, I want to talk
to you about this lawsuit."
He took me to a room where
they kept the work boxes.
We went there and he said,
"What's this lawsuit about?
We don't hate you guys?
We may hate the blacks,
but we don't hate you."
[ Laughter ]
And I found out that he was kidding,
but our case was not about hate,
that was the last thing the bureau
felt against the Hispanic agents.
They just set us aside
and forgot about us.
And it wasn't just management, the
FBI Agents Association was formed
for the purpose of attacking
or defending themselves
against management.
In the late 70s when the cointel
program and other programs started
and the FBI agents were accused
of what they call black bag jobs,
going in without warrants
and things like that,
and they started making
the agents scapegoats,
so they started the
Agents Association
to protect the agents
against management.
Well when the Hispanics
filed a lawsuit and it was
against management, it wasn't
against our colleagues,
the FBI Agents Association
decided to side on the side
of management and not the agents.
FBI agents are supposed
to be strong, ethical,
just, truthful, inquisitive.
Let me read for you just
a minute from the book
about Ed Mireles who
is our guest here.
This is one day in the life if Ed.
Two FBI agents, Jerry Grove, Ben
Grogan, died in a hail of gunfire
as five other wounded agents battled
through the carnage
of April 11th, 1986.
A crime perpetrated by two armed
and dangerous U.S. army
rangers trained killers.
Face with the superior firepower of
assault rifles, the FBI agents stood
as a team with a purpose
and defended one another.
Agents lay dead and
wounded in a quick exchange
as over 130 bullets
created blood chaos.
As the two bank robbers attempted
to escape in a stolen FBI car,
Special Agent Edmundo Mireles Jr
despite being dazed from one gunshot
to the head and another that left
his left arm paralyzed while still
under fire sat up, supported
himself off a nearby car.
Then using his body, his knees,
and his right hand cocked
and fired all the rounds in
a shotgun at the suspects.
Faced with death his
fear dissolved into anger
and determination to
stop the killers.
Ed dropped the empty shotgun,
pulled his revolver out
and staggered towards the
getaway car, shot and emptied all
of his ammunition leaving
the perpetrators dead.
He had survived and in recognition
of his actions the FBI awarded him
the first ever FBI Medal of Valor.
Yet even before that dark and tragic
day Ed had survived other shots,
wounds of discrimination,
when he sensed rejection
from within his FBI community.
Ed would testify on the
discrimination at the bureau,
but not as a class member.
I remember Ed's testimony
on the day he testified.
He was wringing his hands.
He was crotched.
His head was down.
He spoke in a low voice.
His voice cracked at times.
He was nervous.
You may want to ask him why
a different Ed than the one
that won the Medal of Valor?
Let me add that three agents
cried while testifying.
One of them was my
compadre Greg Rodriguez.
Greg and I were partners in Chicago.
We worked the FALN cases.
We knocked on doors
morning, day and night.
We worked 16 hour days.
Michael Deutsch, who was
an attorney for the FALN,
every time he sued the FBI they
would have Greg's name and my name
on the affidavit, but some
days we weren't even present,
some days we weren't even working.
We had a reputation of going
out there and knocking on doors
and trying to solve cases.
Try testifying against
a dysfunctional family
or a dysfunctional school you
attended or a religion you follow
that convers up abuse or an agency
that represents Lady Justice,
mother burial [phonetic],
father faith,
fidelity, bravery and integrity.
Testifying against the
bureau wasn't easy for me.
It wasn't easy for Ed.
During the trail there was a lot of
words that came out; tamale squad.
Tamale squad was when agents
first came in in 1970.
The bureau didn't know what to do
so they put them all in one squad
and so we started called
ourselves the tamale squad.
The Taco Circuit started.
The Taco Circuit -a friend of
mine last weekend, Evan Dobbs,
told me he says, "That's the
first time I've heard taco used
as an adjective."
And what was happening was that the
bureau was -the supervisor was going
out into the bullpen and
saying, "You Mireles,
go out we need you [inaudible] 90
days in Puerto Rico, in Los Angeles
or New York or wherever on a case."
But in that bullpen was
also Adams, Williams,
Jones who also spoke Spanish, but
it was easier for the supervisor
to see Ed Mireles because
of the color of his skin,
Ed Mireles because his surname
for him to get those duties.
He wasn't thinking
it was out of abuse.
But it became abuse when we started
telling how come it's not happening
to them.
And that's when they got upset
that you question management
and so that's when
the retaliation began.
On promotions there were agents that
were more qualified than others,
and it was a good old boy system.
A good old boy system;
picking your friends is easier,
working with your friends is easier
than somebody who's touched all
the bases and you don't know them
and you say, "Well I'll
just pick my friend."
And that happens quite a bit.
So it was that type
of discrimination
that was going on in the bureau.
The other word that came up in
the bureau was angle helper.
And angle helper was because
we would get assigned cases
and we would have responsibility
for them.
When the responsibility came,
let's say Smith had a case
that needed Spanish speakers,
they would take us off our cases,
go work with them, come back,
and since they didn't speak Spanish
we would have to transcribe them.
So we actually became what
they call angle helpers.
There's also in the book there's
when Mat Perez was in El Paso
as the ASAC he told his SAC he
says, "We need more Spanish speakers
because these people are
getting drained from their work.
And the SAC said, "Well who's
going to talk to the bankers?"
As if Spanish speakers
don't talk to the bankers.
Spanish speakers speak English too.
El Navajo [phonetic] in his
book testified to the fact
that he was assigned to Puerto
Rico and was an angle helper
because agents were
being sent to Puerto Rico
that didn't speak Spanish so he
would have to go work their cases,
work his cases, and the term
angle helper came up in trial.
FBI director Comey visited El Paso
and said, "Anytime you have people
in power, you're going to have at
some point people who go sideways
as a result of that power.
You just have to hold
people accountable."
That's what I was doing,
holding people accountable.
I did not testify against
the bureau.
colleagues.
I love the bureau, I
love my colleagues,
I testified against management.
The people I worked for.
The people I worked with.
I was in management.
The FBI is perfect.
Individuals are less than perfect.
I am less than perfect.
Director Comey knows that
the FBI is constructed
as a perfect organization.
I want to keep it that way.
Educated, experienced
and responsible Hispanic agents
had the ideal work ethic required
for premiere law enforcement agency.
Hispanics had learned to
accept their humble beginnings,
their accents, their language,
their culture, their surnames,
their skin color, who they were.
It was time for FBI
management to learn Hispanic men
and women deserve career
opportunities.
Hispanics are just as good as
any other agents in trench coats,
wingtip shoes, fedoras, or FBI raid
jackets whether they have blue eyes,
green eyes, or beautiful
brown eyes like mine.
Let's see if you agree with me that
the actions of some supervisors
within the FBI were evil.
I got assigned to Mexico City as a
case agent for Kiki Camarena and in
between that time I got a
call from a person who wanted
to give me some information.
Apparently he had given the
information to the office before
and nobody did anything about it.
So I called him in, listened to
him, spent the whole day with him
and told him I needed about
three days to write it out
and I would call him back so I could
make sure I got everything right.
I did and he came back
and we made some changes
and sent it out to the bureau.
And he was hiding -he
was a bodyguard for one
of the president's cousins
who was running drugs.
And so he decided when the
earthquake came he decided to hide
out and he decided he wanted to
get out of what he was doing.
At that time we had two good
cases that were FBI cases
that we could have used him for,
but my boss said, "Hand
him over to DEA."
He didn't want anything
to do with him.
So we handed him over to DEA and DEA
was working the Kiki Camarena case,
which was a high priority case.
He was running financially low
on his money, and so I told him,
I said, "Why don't you just leave?
Go to the U.S. now and
wait for DEA to call you."
And he said, "Well I
don't have any money.
I have two guns."
And so I fixed it up for a security
guard company to buy the guns
from him, which they
were authorized to do.
They bought the guns, I got the
money, gave it to the informant.
And the guns ended up in the
truck of the car the first day
and my boss saw it and I had
told him what had happened
and did nothing.
A year later I was accused
by customs and the DEA
that I was selling guns to
informants, which was false.
And my boss I told him, I said,
"This has to do with the incident
about the two guns from Kermit."
Kermit is just a name
that I used for him.
So Kermit left Huston and became an
informant for customs and for DEA
and that's where that
information came from.
So my boss sends a note out to
headquarters and I was accused
of criminal activity, lack of
candor and insubordination to cover
up an event that occurred
a year earlier.
I knew I could prove
I committed no crime.
I also knew unless its
orange of my alma mater UTEP,
I wouldn't look good
in an orange jumpsuit.
[ Laughter ]
However, the insubordination
and lack
of candor charges we're
my boss's word against me.
I requested the FBI polygraph me
to prove I follows all my boss's
instructions and that I was candid
at any inquiry of the investigation.
The 1, 2, 3 levels above my
boss refused to polygraph me.
Who's running this place?
Kim Jong-Il?
[ Laughter ]
I was alive.
I had to pinch myself.
It was not a dream.
I had to do something.
I paid a retired FBI
polygrapher to examine me.
I passed. The bureau
paid no attention
to the results and demoted me.
Attempts to fix things
within the FBI failed.
All 1, 2, 3 levels of leadership
management weren't interested.
I could not understand what
integrity or the FBI meant
to those managers, what emotion was
destroying their sense of reasoning,
destroying their sense
of responsibility,
destroying the essence of
investigations within the FBI.
I knew what the FBI meant to me.
I was embarrassed and sad
that I had to take my case
to an outside agency, the
Merit Systems Protection Board,
who reviewed my case and
overturned my demotion.
The story of Mat Perez is worse.
I'm going to deputize all of
you and make you SACs in charge
of an office, an office of 62
people; 55 in your field office
and the rest out in the field.
Just to the north of us
you have a Navy shooting
where 10 sailors are shot.
2 are killed.
That's a major case.
On the south of us you have
an [inaudible] Air Force base
that's bombed.
25 planes are destroyed,
12 completely.
Just on the east of
us -east is this way.
Just on the east of us you have
a Navy ship that was bombed.
And to the west of us you
have a police corruption case
where you're investigating
over 40 officers for corruption
and they're assigned to help
you with investigations.
Now what would you do now that
you're in charge of your office?
You ask for help.
You ask for help from headquarters.
Headquarters sent him support.
He was asking for specifically
for Spanish speakers
and for 90 days they
turned him down.
They sent him whoever
they could for 30 days.
If you've ever been to
Puerto Rico, you have streets
that don't make any sense,
the language is different.
It's a difficult place
to get situated.
So you had agents that were
coming it, you had to situate them
and then they would
turn around and leave
in 30 days -they weren't
being much help.
So if they turn down manpower is
that discrimination
or mismanagement?
I'd go with mismanagement
at the beginning.
Now you need computers
and you ask for computers
and the executive director says,
"Well you're behind Springfield.
You're 7th on the list
behind Springfield division."
Springfield division
is a small office too.
But instead of looking
at what the situation is
in Puerto Rico they put
you 8th on the list.
There were 7 people ahead of you.
The admiral on the base
seeing that people have died,
people are getting Purple
Hearts, knows the urgency,
so he contacts the CIA
and the CIA gives us state
of the art computers right away.
Mat calls headquarters, asks
for computer personnel
to run the computers.
They say no.
Is that mismanagement or
is that discrimination?
Then he hears from a
friend of his who's
up in headquarters the
executive director says,
"Let's see how he plans to
man those computers now."
For me that's discrimination
and that's evil.
No leader, no manager, no one
is as important as any agency.
No one has the authority
to undermine agency values whether
it's the Library of Congress,
a corporation, or the FBI.
Trump was recently
elected as president.
He came out and said that
Mexicans are rapists.
That Mexicans are murderers.
That Mexicans are bringing
drugs into this country.
And I'm OK with that because
Scottish people are rapists.
Scottish people are murderers.
Scottish people also bring
drugs into this country.
What bothered me was when he said,
"I assume some of them are OK."
When he said that I
said, "I've been living
in this country for a long time.
I've got five generations
on my father's side that are
from the New Mexico area, which
at one point was part of Mexico.
I've been in this country
longer than many others."
When he said, "I assume
some of them are OK"
that means he doesn't know Mexicans.
He doesn't know Mexican Americans.
He accuses a judge of Mexican
heritage that he would be unfair.
He doesn't know Mexicans.
My parents -not my parents, but my
grandparents had land taken away
from them in Mexico, in New Mexico.
They took it away because
the deeds were in Spanish.
And now we became part of the U.S.
so they said, "We can't read that.
We don't honor that."
So they gave it to settlers that
were moving into the New Mexico area
and other parts of the west.
I grew up in Lakeside, a
subdivision of El Paso.
Now you may think that
sounds aesthetically great,
but my view was a view of the ditch.
But kids in grade school made fun of
me because I had holes in my shoes.
I had holes in my shoes,
but it wasn't me,
I didn't have holes in myself.
I grew up in El Paso with a great
group of friends: Oscar, Joe,
Ernie, or Robert [phonetic].
We went everywhere together.
When we were in high
school or in college we had
to develop our interpersonal skills.
We also had to make ends meet,
so we would crash parties,
weddings and quinceaneras.
We'd call it networking with
food and drinks [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
We're still waiting on the
movie The Quinceanera Crashers.
[ Laughter ]
Some nights we would
crash at one of our homes.
If it wasn't at Oscar's
house we would have
to stop at his house first.
It wasn't to ask permission,
but it was to pick
up his blanket that he slept with.
For Oscar Barajas, who we
called Cook [phonetic],
that blanket represented
his security.
We complained the first night, but
then we just accepted him as is.
Now before you think this
person speaking to you hung
out with a bunch of wusses and
cried on the stand when he testified
against the FBI, let me
say that Cook was shot
and killed having dinner at
Howard Johnson's in Albuquerque
when two armed robbers came
in and threatened the cashier.
They were looking for money
then they planned to kidnap her.
He intervened by trying to calm the
gunman down and protect the cashier.
He did not retreat for
his security blanket.
He rose to the occasion of
knowing his identity of who he was.
Who he was cost him his life.
The robbers took his life, but they
did not take away his identity.
Ed Mireles did the same thing
when he had to stand up.
Every day you are creating
a new you.
Your personal identity is in
a constant state of evolution.
We all have the power
to reinvent ourselves
and create a new empowered identity
that expands what is
possible in our lives.
The key is to take conscious control
of the beliefs we are creating
about ourselves so they can power
us towards what we desire most.
The power to tap into our tremendous
potential comes from our identity.
How we define ourselves and having
faith in what we can achieve.
Have faith to let go of
who you are at this moment
and accept how far you can reach.
Your reach has enormous
potential beyond what's thought
to be possible.
Let me do a Miami Senate.
[ Laughter ]
Our identity is the
strongest influence
to our happiness and
our actions in life.
Living inconsistent to
who you are creates a life
of disappointment,
frustration and stress.
You don't want to live
someone's perception of you.
You want to live and
embrace your authentic self.
Embrace your deepest beliefs, your
deepest fears, your deepest strength
to create the almighty
harmony in your life.
I want you to please look
at the person next to you.
Please vow that you won' kill
the potential in them or others.
We are here to enjoy
the gift of life.
Vow the day [phonetic] from evil
thoughts that you will not diminish,
disregard, or steal anyone's
identity of who they are.
None of them knows
what inside of you,
and you don't know
what's inside of them.
Just as no one knew what
was inside of Oscar Barajas.
In the face of death he knew
the value of right and wrong.
Faced with death he cared
for someone he knew nothing
about more than his own life.
Only you know your true identity.
Only you know your true potential.
Only you know who you are.
Let no one steal your
identity of who you are.
It's your right to inner
peace, your right to fairness,
your right to the almighty
gift of life.
Thank you all.
I'll open it up for questions.
I also want to ask Ed Mireles
to stand up here with me
and for you to honor him.
[ Applause ]
You can ask him any questions or ask
me any questions that you'd like.
Yes sir.
>> I'm here because my father
has a good friend who was
with I don't think the FBI
[inaudible] the Department
of Homeland Security
[inaudible] last year
or so awarded to the Mason case.
[Inaudible].
My question is as your case and
any other case like that continue,
what does the FBI and
Department of Homeland Security
or government [phonetic]
agencies do to try to make
that process more justice [phonetic]
for people versus that [inaudible]?
>> Samuel Martinez: I filed
an EEO case on January 1st.
I pulled an agent from vacation
because my 90 days was going to end
on the next day on
the 2nd of January.
So I pulled him off vacation and I
said, "You're taking my EEO case."
So I filed an EEO case and
it took 7 years to resolve.
What I wanted for them
to do was take the lies
out of my personnel file.
That's what I wanted.
I took them 7 years to do that.
I didn't see it coming and
those 7 years just chipped away
at what justice meant
to me and the FBI,
what investigations
meant within the FBI.
They would assign people
to investigate EEO cases
and they would say, "Well
you can go over there,
but just ask him this
part of the question.
Don't ask him on this
side of the questions."
So, you know, if somebody
had told me and I had a badge
for the FBI, I'd say, "No.
Get somebody else.
I'm not doing that."
I just couldn't do it.
But I see it happening.
I know that EEO cases
sometimes they're not as big
as what they -but people
get defensive.
Supervisors get defensive when
a subordinate says something
about them and that's the
last thing they need to do.
I wasn't going to talk
about it, but just think
of the Ferguson case, you know.
Was it a race thing?
We hear it is, but
what about attitudes?
Could it just have been attitudes
where police had a bad day
and a young kid who had just
stolen something had a bad day?
And if we start investigating
things from that point in
and actually start negotiating.
The EEO actually needs good
negotiators, they need to find
out what it is, because people
get defensive, you know?
Racism is thrown out, prejudice or
bigoted is thrown out real quick
and so people get defensive,
they put up a wall automatically,
and so it's hard to talk through
that wall when you're trying
to get something settled.
But I don't see there
any -to be honest
with you I haven't reviewed any
EEO cases, but I know that back
when I was doing the book
it was EEO cases less
than 10 percent there was
some kind of findings.
So you think is it possible that 9
out of 10 people are
making up false claims?
I think there's a lot of unfairness.
Just like I spoke about the
unfairness -I think it was unfair
for Judge Sessions to be removed
from the bureau as a director
when he flew out to San Francisco
to see his daughter in a ballet
and also visit the office.
But the previous director would go
and talk to boys club and then go
and ski and play tennis is the
mountains of Denver, Colorado.
So for me the system is unfair,
it's not always discrimination.
But I really can't answer to
you if they're getting shorter,
but they should, they should.
And if you ask for a good
negotiator to negotiate some kind
of agreement -but it's kind of hard
to prove discrimination
just like I said.
If you're in charge of an office
and there's 4 major cases going on
and somebody is slow at sending
you manpower, is it stupidity?
Is it mismanagement?
When do you put the finger
on its discrimination?
And discrimination
ought to be looked
at as is it unfair
for you to do this?
Is it unfair for you to send people
to Nebraska on a case extra manpower
when they have less going on?
That's when you start
determining what discrimination is.
I don't if Ed you want
to add something.
No.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ed Mireles: You did a good job.
>> Samuel Martinez: Yes.
>> I have a question and I'm sorry,
I apologize, I came
in a little late.
What was the outcome of the case?
[Inaudible].
>> Samuel Martinez: The
outcome was that the FBI won,
won in restauration because the
Hispanics won as the plaintiffs.
The FBI lost as a case and
from that loss the FBI won
because as Roberto said
women were promoted
at an unprecedented
rate within the FBI.
I had a chance to go before a
[inaudible] police seniority panel
and say, "I should be
at a grade 15 position."
And I justified my
position and I got it.
Once you're given an opportunity,
you're basically saying,
"Hey, let me fail.
Give me the opportunity to fail.
That's all I want.
Just an opportunity to prove myself.
That's what I want.
Give it to me."
And there's Hispanics that
have failed and there's Anglos
that have failed and
blacks have failed.
But then there's been a lot of them
that have surprised
people and been successful.
So yes, we won the lawsuit.
Hispanics didn't get any money.
It was basically a [inaudible]
place seniority promotion
where we were asked to go
before an individual panel
to justify our positions.
But the FBI won, the FBI won
because it became a better agency.
Supervisors became more sensitive
and secret service, bureau prisons,
DEA, all these other
agencies that were
in law enforcement they opened their
books and said, "We need to look
at ourselves and see
what's going on.
Because if the FBI can
lose with the Department
of Justice backing them
up, we're going to lose."
So there was a lot of changes.
I spoke at the Commodity Futures
Trading Commission last week
and a couple of agents from the
IG's office came up and said, "Hey,
you've made it better for us."
And I think we did.
I think IRS I even got notices from
[inaudible] that we did it better.
So the FBI won.
On the books they lost,
but the FBI really won.
>> Ed Mireles: I just want
to echo what Sam said.
First off, to clear the
record, I wasn't as rich
as Sam was when he was growing up.
[ Laughter ]
He had shoes.
No, but Sam is absolutely right.
The suit was righteous, OK?
It was never about money.
Never about money.
I mean nobody was saying, "Hey,
I want a million dollars
to make me whole."
It was never about the money.
It was about being given
a fair chance, you know,
being given the same chance
that your colleagues had, OK?
And Sam is also right the FBI
became a better organization
after the suit.
However, if I could take
you back to that era,
you would think their dog died.
[ Laughter ]
Because they were appalled
that they had lost a case.
And, you know, for us
it was a no-brainer.
I mean how could you
not lose the case
for all the stuff that
you were doing?
And like Sam said, you know,
it wasn't done out of evil,
it was just done out of incompetence
or stupidity or being uneducated.
It's hard to describe.
Don't get me wrong, I ran
into some bigots in the FBI.
I know a couple that
were outright bigots, OK?
Against Hispanics and blacks,
and thank god they're
retired and long gone.
But the FBI couldn't
believe it had lost a case.
And then when the court told them
what they had to do, you know,
it was like the remedy was
worse than the actual disease.
And I think that -if Sam will back
me up on this- I think the fact
that the bureau had to...
[ Laughter ]
Had to partake in the
remedy that the court set
out that was probably worse than
having to go through the trial
because I mean it's like
dragging a spoiled little kid
down to the doctor's office
to get a shot, you know?
But Sam is absolutely right
the FBI and the government
in general became a better
organization and especially women.
My wife was an FBI
agent at the time,
you know, she became a supervisor.
And probably because of the suit
there were more opportunities
for women that came open.
Thank you Sam.
>> Samuel Martinez:
Any more questions?
Yes sir.
>> Yes. You testified at
the hearing or at the trial,
but you weren't actually
part of the lawsuit.
Can you explain why?
>> Ed Mireles: Well it's
like Sam said, you know,
I grew up -I'm a product of the-
well my grandparents were a
product of the Great Depression.
My parents were a product
of the World War II era.
And I was their product.
I can't say Korean War.
But I grew up in an environment
where family, you know,
the great spirit, church,
country, respect for family,
respect for elders, love,
honor and all that stuff.
And I'm a firm believer
in in that, you know.
A friend of mine told me once, "Ed,
you're the worst employee
to supervise."
I said, "Why?"
He said, "Because you're not loyal."
He said, "You're not
loyal to any individual."
He said, "You're loyal to causes.
You're loyal to the constitution.
You're loyal to the Bill of Rights.
You're loyal to the rule of law."
He said, "If somebody stands in your
way and he's not following the rule
of law or not following the
constitution," he said, "Ed,
you'll screw him over
in a heartbeat."
And so I mean I very
truly feel that way.
The rule of law, OK, that's
what we all stand for.
Justice and equality for everybody.
I mean that's what guides me.
That's my North Star
I guess you could say.
And I looked at the FBI
as my second family, OK?
And then I found out it
was like -it was a shock
that maybe your family wasn't
as wholesome as you thought.
And it was very difficult for
me to actually conceive the fact
that the FBI would
be doing these things
to his children, to employees.
And when the first started I said,
"Well I support the suit in spirit,
but I have not directly
been involved
or been a victim of discrimination.
But then as the suit
progressed I talked to more
and more people involved in
the suit and then as it turned
out I was subject to a transfer
from Washington, D.C., to Miami
and there were some
logistical issues
where the FBI transferred
someone from Miami to Washington
at a full-paid transferred, but
when it came time to transfer me
to Miami they said, "Well
we're doing you a favor
by sending you to Miami.
You have to pay your
own way to Miami."
It's like wait a minute,
isn't the government supposed
to transfer its employees?
They said, "Yes, but we're going
to send your paycheck to Miami.
If you want it you
got to go down there."
So anyway, that happened after
the lawsuit had been going
on for a while so I
joined at the very end
as a witness for the Perez side.
And it was very difficult, it
was very difficult to testify.
It was like -as Sam
said- it was like one
of the most difficult things I've
done, probably more so or almost
as bad as getting shot because
I felt I was betraying a trust,
you know, against an organization
that's bigger than anyone.
It was bigger than me.
But then I stopped to
rationalize it, you know,
the trust had already been
betrayed coming this way.
Trust is a two-way street, OK?
And when I realized the trust had
been betrayed coming this way,
I didn't feel so bad when I thought
I was betraying the trust going
that way.
Hope that answers your question.
>> Samuel Martinez: I joined the
lawsuit and I had a reason for it,
but if I didn't have a reason
for it I still would have seen it
with the assignments and being
part of the Taco Circuit,
part of the angle helpers.
I mean I was dragged
all over the place.
Agents liked me because I did their
investigations and I did their work.
But I thought it was unfair
and that's why the judge
found systemic discrimination
within the FBI because of the system
that they had in place and using it,
so I would have joined even if these
incidents hadn't happened to me.
Any other questions?
>> Ed Mireles: Just to
follow up on what Sam said,
our promotion system is based
on your performance, OK?
How many arrests have you
made in the year 2016?
How many people have
you interviewed?
How many people have you indicted?
How many people have you,
you know, prosecuted?
And so on and so forth.
If you are TDY from your office,
from your cases, for 3 months
and some cases 6 months, OK?
That's 6 months of you
not working, you're stuck.
So you have less stats, less
evidence to prove your worth,
prove your contribution
to the cause.
And the other guys, the guys
that Sam would have to help,
they would get their
stats, you know.
Sam would help them arrest people
and indict people and
interview people.
But he never got the credit.
The other guy got the credit, OK?
So it's like Sam's like
[phonetic], "Hey Sam,
you only have 2 arrests this
year and Bill over there has 22."
It's like, "We're going
to promote Bill."
It's like wait a minute, I helped
Bill with those 22 arrests.
So that's how it affected
the individuals.
>> Samuel Martinez:
What Ed's talking
about is your statistical
accomplishments.
But then I spoke last week it's
also your administrative profile.
And your administrative profile
is sometimes more important
than your statistics.
If you look at some of
the way promotions happen
within an agency it's who you
know and not what you know
and so sometimes that happens.
You have a question?
>> Just a quick follow-up.
Was [phonetic] there a mechanism
now in place as a follow-up to kind
of that discrepancy where
someone assists in helping you
by providing translation
or arrests, etc.,
like now they get credit as well?
>> Samuel Martinez: Well now
they have Spanish speakers
that aren't agents.
A lot of them are doing
what they call the wires;
interceding the conversations.
They have them doing that.
But as far as -I know that
they were making attempts
to hire more Spanish speakers.
One of the things I didn't mention
was that if you were Anglo and came
in under the Spanish
program, there was a period
where they allowed you to opt out.
Well that policy never
said it's only for Anglos
so some Hispanic read
it and said, "Hey,
I want to get out of the program."
I said, "No you can't
because you're Hispanic."
So it was unfair in that system.
But yes, I'm pretty sure that
there's still cases out there
where somebody needs a Spanish
speaker because he goes into an area
where a case agent
may not speak Spanish.
I'm not sure how they're
accredited now, but the burden
on Hispanics has diminished.
I spoke to an agent last week
who came out to the presentation
and he said it's a lot
better than what it was.
Yes, madam?
>> Do you have any advice for
young Hispanics entering the FBI
or other organizations like the FBI?
Is it really just networking or
are there other things [inaudible]?
>> Samuel Martinez:
Do I have any advice
for people coming into the FBI?
Yes. It's a great organization.
There's a lot of excitement.
Each day is different.
You work with good people.
[ Laughter ]
Mostly good people -until they get
into management then
they become evil.
But no, I have great friends and
great colleagues in the bureau.
It's a great career and I
recommend that field of work.
They've now gone from the
criminal side more to security side
because of the terrorism
threats in this country.
But it's an exciting field and
it's a great opportunity for women
and women are promoted
and they're in charge
of offices and everything else.
So it's a good opportunity.
I have some books that are
signed back there to sell.
It's also on audible.com, but if
you live in D.C. it's under 10 hours
so in 2 commutes you
can go through the book.
[ Laughter ]
But thank you very much for
having me and having Ed up here.
We appreciate it.
[ Laughter ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.